on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour une
vidéo réalisée en partenariat avec
huawei pour vous parler de ce produit là
je ne sais pas si ça vous parle si dans
le titre ça vous parler c'est le mec pas
trop il ya beaucoup de paix mais vous
allez voir la solution est intéressante
c'est en fait une tablette qui se
transforme en ordinateur avec à
l'intérieur beaucoup de puissance
beaucoup de performances pas mal de
possibilités
un clavier un stylet et je pense que ça
va plaire à pas mal de monde
mais avant toute chose si ce n'est pas
déjà fait je vous invite à vous abonner
à la chaîne pourquoi parce que vous
présente beaucoup d'objets tech des
nouveautés des smartphones des tablettes
des monts des ordinateurs beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup choc et je vous donne
des astuces des bons plans pour réussir
votre vie numérique donc vous invite
donc à venir cliquez sur le bouton
s'abonner et puis il ya évidemment à
activer la cloche
la première chose à voir là dessus ça va
être toute la partie design on a une
tablette qui n'est pas extrêmement
grande
on a un format qui reste très compact
qu'on peut tenir très facilement à une
main point très très positif qui est
très cool votre stylet et aimante et
maintenant le point négatif c'est comme
vous le voyez si vous faites pas
attention il va se décrocher assez
facilement ce que je vous conseille vous
glisser dans une sacoche lorsque vous
transporter vous éviter de le malade est
comme ça dans les transports en commun
lorsque vous l'ouvrez ça se présente
comme un livre vous avez aimé sur la
partie écran voulait bien sûr le parti
clavier alors je vous le dis tout de
suite comme ça vous le saurez ici c'est
un clavier qui en qwerty
parce que ça des premiers modèles que
j'ai récupéré et que vous vous l'aurez
bien évidemment avec un clavier azerty
dans la mesure où vous êtes en france
point qui est sympa et qu'on voit tout
de suite c'est qu'ici vous avez deux
bandes
alors ces deux bandes elles vous servent
à dire trouver la position exacte pour
venir poser la première c'est comme ça
et la deuxième c'est comme ça vous
l'aurez donc plus ou moins droite en
fonction de vos besoins et en fonction
de vos usages un instant t cémenté ça
tient ses robustes ces pratiques
on est donc sur un produit compact léger
très facile de prise en main avec sa
petite cover que vous avez là qui via le
protéger mais si vous ne souhaitez pas
avant la cover vous pouvez l'enlever si
vous êtes en france et vous avez une
seule couleur c'est la couleur milne est
greg loyer si c'est un petit gris très
sympa à gris mat qui ne prend pas les
traces de doigts de toute façon les
traces de doigts vous en fichez puisque
vous pouvez prendre
l'étui qui donnerait à la fin le tarif
de l'étui du style et que vous avez deux
côtés le tarif de la tablette vous
saurez tout dans quelques instants
d'ailleurs si vous n'êtes pas en france
dites moi où est ce que vous êtes dès
maintenant en commentaire vous avez
d'eau qui est en fibre de verre un
châssis en aluminium un produit qui pèse
à peine 4 192 g mais là où ça devient
encore plus intéressant c'est la face
avant pourquoi parce que vous avez un
grand écran poinçonnet avec une caméra
faut mettre de côté ou de l'autre
ça vous connaissez le principe ça vous
dégage l'écran et c'est sans doute à ces
pratiques eh bien oui parce que vous
avez un taux d'occupation qui est
complètement aiguille vous avez des
bords qui sont assez fin de tous les
côtés la petite caméra qu'est plan qui
si on en parle dans quelques instants
cette petite caméra vous êtes un écran
lcd c'est une dali ps de 10,8 pouces qhd
2560 par 1600 pixels avec une gamme de
couleurs dci p 3 ce qui est très positif
sur cet écran sais que vous avez
beaucoup de place pour autre visionnage
maintenant ce que je vais mais un tout
petit peu moins c'est qu'effectivement
eh bien voyez vous avez ce petit trou
qui vient son côté ce petit point son
convoi lorsque vous regardez des films
des séries du contenu que vous jouez on
voit c'est pas très gênant c'est un
parti pris de la part de huawei l'idée
doivent s est ce dire là dessus
eh bien on va dégager l'écran va laisser
l'espace disponible pour le spectateur
pour l'utilisation pour la productivité
font tout ce que vous voulez en faire et
pour faire ce choix on va utiliser
l'idée de mettre un petit point sont ici
pour avoir une caméra de cette fille
c'est un choix stratégique
il est pas mal on aimera ou on aimera
pas je suis pas toujours très fan des
points sont là où ils sont positionnés
parce que on les voit malgré tout les
vues où il est là voyez sur le côté on a
tendance à l'oublier quand même assez
rapidement bon c'est pas très très
graves pour tout ce qui est visionnage
vidéo vous allez pouvoir regarder vos
vidéos sur youtube depuis votre
navigateur vous aurez accès à netflix my
canal mais pas en hd actuellement vous
serez uniquement en sd à 5 176 p c'est
pour une question de drm une question de
droite ou ça se règlera dans le temps
huawei est en train de travailler dessus
pour que dans quelques mois vous n'ayez
pas cette contrainte
mais que serait une tablette comme celle
là si on n'avait pas de l'audio de
qualité alors point qui est vraiment
sympa c'est que vous avez deux haut
parleurs de chaque côté c'est la même
source une source stéréo c'est à dire
que là vous avez de ce côté là de ce
côté là mais c'est du son stéréo je sais
que c'est difficile de se rendre compte
comme ça mais là
dans le sens porno ne sont pas en bas on
prend en pleine tronche et pour
l'expérience multimédia gaming tout ce
que vous voulez sall a merveilleusement
bien
malheureusement là dessus vous n'allez
pas avoir de prise jack pas content avec
ce soir que nous fournit huawei avec
c'est ce petit accessoire là vous allez
pouvoir avoir une petite prise jack sur
un port usb c'est bon alors c'est une
fois de plus un petit accessoire c'est
pas très pratique ce petit tuyau qui est
tendu comme ça ça pour moi c'est pas
idéal mais en tout cas c'est là ça
existe et si vous voulez en tout cas
vous pouvez faire mais si vous voulez
pas le faire que vous voulez quand même
utiliser un casque
il faut savoir que vous avez du
bluetooth 5.1 tu vous permettra
d'appareiller les casques bluetooth que
vous souhaitez très facilement mais ce
n'est pas tout puisque vous pouvez
utiliser également pour faire de la
vidéoconférence pour appeler vos amis
notamment face à cette petite caméra que
vous avez à l'avant vous avez pas moins
de cinq micros vous les voyez c'est tout
les petites routes vous avez ici l'idée
de ces micro c'est de capter votre voix
au mieux jusqu'à quatre mètres de
distance ça va venir
isolez votre voix et la détacher du
bruit environnant pour remplissent très
bien vous entendre et pour vous puissiez
parler à vos amis sans aucune pollution
côté performances huawei nous ont mis ce
qu'ils font de mieux ils ont intégré le
kirin 990 vous avez si giga de ram
lp ddr4 x 128 giga de stockage en ufr
3.0 et vous permettra d'avoir une
écriture et une lecture très rapide côté
graphique on a une manie j'ai 76 en
boule de ça vous avez l'optimisation
logicielle qui s'appelle le gpu turbo et
si on veut sortir un peu du côté fiche
technique ce qu'il faut vraiment retenir
c'est que cette tablette vous permettra
de gérer le multitâche très facilement
de pouvoir jouer à des jeux vesle des
jeux très performant sans absolument
aucun problème sans latence sans lag
l'autonomie est bonne avec aussi une
grosse batterie de 7250 millions terreur
ça vous permettra de tenir suffisamment
longtemps dans le temps une tablette
c'est pas comme un smartphone pas vous
dire si vous allez la garder un jour
deux ou trois jours quatre jours cinq
jours et compagnie ça dépendra de vous
de vos usages de ce que vous allez en
faire si vous passez des heures à faire
des grandes sessions de jeu bien
évidemment vous allez consommer
davantage de batterie mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que vous avez un chargeur
de 20 watts qui inclut et que ces
petites bêtes là est compatible charge
40 watts
si vous voulez la recharge est encore
plus vite vouloir changer avec de l'usbc
3.1 et en plus de ça puisque huawei on
met en place toute sa stratégie
d'écosystème vous avez 2
la charge l'inversé est laid que vous
pouvez prendre votre tablette pour venir
charger vos écouteurs pour venir charger
votre smartphone c'est pas la charge la
plus rapide et ça vous permettra de
raviver l'autonomie des smartphones des
écouteurs et compagnie que sais-je
encore il faut savoir qu'avec le
chargeur de 40 watts vous allez pouvoir
recharger de 0 à 100% en 1h42 et que
seulement 30 minutes de charge vous
repartez pour 5 heures d'autonomie
ici on tombe sur eux mêmes 8 10.1 basé
sur un android disent vous ne retrouvez
pas ici de pelé store de google mais la
galerie dans 4 3 aux applications snap
chatte tic toc et compagnie je vous ai
fait une vidéo dédiée sur la bière
reeves expliquant comment trouver toutes
vos applications je vous ai mis le lien
en bas dans la description puisque les
soldes n 17 pour la productivité vous
avez un mode qui est extrêmement
intéressant vous venez de chercher là il
est ici c'est ce qu'on appelle le mode
bureau le mode bureau va transformer
votre tablette en un véritable petit
ordinateur vous accédez et vous arrivez
sur le mei des stocks
et là vous avez tout d'un petit
ordinateur avec ici votre barre
d'information votre menu où vous accédez
à toutes vos applications ici vous
trouvez tous vos paramètres de la même
manière mais vous pouvez bien l'utiliser
très facilement en venant fermer ici
avec les croix bond assez classique vous
ouvrez vous connaissez l'idée vous
déplacez vos fenêtres pour sortir c'est
très facile vous cliquez là vous quittez
et vous revenez son mode normal
enfin autre point extrêmement important
que cette machine je pouvais faire du
multitâche je prends mon navigateur par
exemple ensuite je viens son côté je
prends mon application n'est beau que je
viens intercalé directement ici donc
l'âge et le multitâche
je peux à la fois naviguer sur internet
à la fois ferme et notent les éditer
très facilement si je le souhaite je
peux venir changer mon application très
facilement multitâche je prends par
exemple la calculatrice je la remplace
ici et si ensuite je quand même venir
utiliser mon application des mots pour
venir griffonné et bien je n'ai qu'à
cliquer dessus
donc je peux avoir jusqu'à trois
fenêtres utilisable très facilement il
ya un autre point je vous avais montré
il n'ya pas longtemps c'est le partage
entre un smartphone et 1 pcsi huawei ça
s'appelle huawei cher et vous pouvez
faire exactement la même chose ici avec
cette tablette le fonctionnement
extrêmement simple vous avez vos
smartphones de huawei vous avez votre
tablette ici et là vous avez une petite
icône pour enrichir ce que vous faites
c'est que vous prenez votre smartphone
vous venez la poser directement dessus
vous sentez la vibration vous vous
connectez et vous retrouvez la copie
parfaite de votre smartphone pourrait
venir naviguer directement depuis votre
smartphone vous voyez ici ou directement
depuis votre écran vous pouvez également
venir connecter votre smartphone depuis
la collaboration multi écrans
vous venez en haut vous chercher ici
collaboration multi écrans bienvenue
vous acceptez votre smartphone propose
de vous connecter vous vous connectez
connexion en cours vous autorisez ici et
voyez ça marche exactement de la même
manière
c'est au tour de collaboration multi
écrans si vous l'a pas trouvée va vous
générez un qr code que vous faites avec
votre smartphone eh bien vous ouvrez
votre caméra vous venez scanner le qr
code il vous propose de vous connecter
vous vous connectez à votre smartphone
également de la même manière dont vous
voyez il ya trois méthodes c'est très
simple ça marche bien pour nous faire
partager directement depuis votre
smartphone vers votre tablette ou depuis
votre tablette vers votre smartphone je
vous invite à consulter la vidéo sur le
web facebook des 15 je vous mets le lien
quelque part par ici je ne sais plus si
c'est là où ça ne nous trompe à chaque
fois et vous verrez tout ce qu'on peut
faire avec moi oui cher c'est vraiment
intéressant et s'enrichissent
globalement l'expérience pour vous
permet d'aller plus loin dans la partie
logicielle est vraiment prendre en main
votre tablette pour envoyer mis en place
un service vip qui s'appelle huawei vip
service tout simplement vous avez deux
possibilités la première signaux klein
gratuite vous passer un coup de fil et
vous avez deux côtés quelqu'un qui va
vous aider dans tous vos problèmes et
deuxième point c'est si vous habitez à
paris ou en ile de france vous pouvez
vous rendre à leur flagship store à
paris opéra et là ils vous aideront
également de la même manière avec vos
appareils way avec toute la partie
application ça vous permettra de
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
avez donc prêt pour ça bravo à noter que
cette machine est 100% compatible avec
la suite microsoft office et également
avec adobe sketch s'apprend ils seront
intéressants pour différentes catégories
de personnes que vous soyez étudiant
vous avez besoin de faire de la prise de
notes de vous promener avec un appareil
petit léger fonctionnel et c'est un
format qui pourrait être vraiment adapté
pour vous pour toutes les personnes qui
ont besoin de productivité je vous dis
que ce soit d'un point de vue
professionnel ou d'un point de vue
familial pour les créatifs avec un
stylet si vous souhaitez faire de la
prise de notes dessinée facilement vous
pouvez le faire ça marche très bien
c'est en gros une tablette à tout faire
qui vous permettra d'avoir des usages
très large très variés jeudi en allant
aussi bien du gaming à la productivité
au dessin à la prise de notes pour tout
ce qui va être photos vidéos vous avez
l'arrière un capteur de 3 mégapixels
couvrait 20.8 un autofocus et vous
pouvez filmer sur quatre cas à 30 images
par seconde tandis qu'à l'avant vous
avez une dernière axel fille de 8
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0
côté photo le résultat est convenable
pourrait faire quelques photos vous
allez pouvoir griffonné est à noter et
ça suffira largement on les voit les
usages sont claires il va s'agir de
productivité que ce soit de la
productivité et familiale pour avoir un
tableur pour tenir des comptes pour
faire des courriers que ce soit du
multimédia vous pouvez venir jouer à des
jeux très facilement piloter une voiture
faire des jeux de combat vous avez
beaucoup de performances on va donc
avoir des usages très large qui sont
aussi bien lié à la maison qu'au monde
du travail mais on va encore plus loin
avec ce clavier qui va aussi bien à
venir vous servir de clavier que des
tuiles lorsque vous aurez mis votre
tablette
à l'intérieur ça vient la protéger très
facilement
ça vient protéger votre caméra on vient
complètement à fleurs il ya un côté
touché premium qui tient bien en main
qu'ils ne glissent pas ce que ça fait
c'est que ça doit transformer votre
tablette en un petit ordinateur avec un
vrai clavier intégré un clavier qui est
pas mal avec une course de touche qui
est assez courte de 1,3 mm
moi personnellement je trouve très
confortable à utiliser jeu peut le
recommander à pas mal de personnes qui
souhaitent vraiment utilisé un petit
clavier pour la productivité quotidienne
ce que j'ai regretté moi par contre ici
c'est qu'il n'y a absolument aucun
trackpad puisque lorsque je suis en
train de l'utiliser comme l'ordinateur
année voyez avec mon doigt
j'ai envie de venir naviguer et je peux
va le faire ce que j'aurais trouvé
intelligent ou nalin ou je sais pas quoi
c'est de pouvoir utiliser mes différents
touchant navigant comme un trackpad et
en pouvant appuyer sur la barre
d'espacement pour valider je sais pas je
trouvais ça bien ce qui manque un petit
truc et ça me fait râler après si on
veut aller encore plus loin
eh bien il faut utiliser le stylet qui
est prévu pour qui vient se ranger juste
là que vous faites et que bull prenait
il à vous pouvez bien naviguer très
facilement dans votre nuit faire tout ce
que vous voulez c'est pratique c'est
simple ça marche bien bon pourquoi pas
le style est très facile à utiliser vous
n'avez qu'à prendre des petits mots à
venir les écrire
vous pouvez venir ensuite les effacer
extrêmement facilement moi ya pas mal de
gestes qui existe j'ai une latence
extrêmement faible de 20 millisecondes
et je peux notamment venir utiliser
l'application qui s'appelle nebo pour le
dessin et pour la prise de notes
donc vous voyez je viens faire beaucoup
de choses avec ça je peux venir a noté
griffonné je peux faire des
mathématiques des calculs en ligne peut
éditer un document que soit pour le
travail que ce soit pour la famille je
peux aussi faire de l'illustration ci
j'ai l'âme d'un illustrateur pain il ya
pas mal de possibilités avec ce style
est maintenant une question que je me
posais concernant l'autonomie concernant
la consommation de batterie du stylet et
également du clavier puisqu'il faut
savoir que le clavier
le stylet viennent puiser dans la
batterie de la tablette le stylet et le
clavier vont consommer à peu près 10% de
la batterie de votre tablette telle
mesure où vous les utilisez en
permanence on arrive donc en autonomie
d'environ 10 heures 40 avec un usage
tablette clavier stylet en lecture vidéo
en 1080p contre 12 heures avec internet
tout seul c'est l'heure de vous parler
des tarifs et des disponibilités de ce
produit c'est un produit qui est en
précommande j'ai tout noter ici noir sur
blanc qui en pré-commande du neuf
jusqu'au 22 juin 2020 au tarif 2 pour la
tablette nue 549 euros 99 le style et 99
euros 99 et si vous voulez le clavier
vous coûtera 129 euros 99 et vous pouvez
les avoir au tarif total de 540 999
autant vous dire que pour le tarif de la
tablette
eh bien vous avez l'ensemble puisque
c'est pour moi l'intérêt réel
alors on peut acheter la tablette tout
seul allait bien et fonctionnent bien
c'est un bon produit
néanmoins c'est vrai que l'intérêt
réside vraiment dans l'idée globale de
venir en complément d'un pc ou en tout
cas de repasser un petit pc ou d'avoir
un petit pc à la maison grâce à ce
produit là je vous dis une fois de plus
ce que je vais venir regretté là dessus
ce qui lui manque c'est le trackpad
mais au-delà de ça on a un produit qui
rentre juste quelle bonne qualité
permettra de faire beaucoup de choses à
vous de me dire maintenant vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire est
ce que vous pourriez être tenté par
cette voie ou et make pad pro 5 g quant
à nous on se retrouve dès demain pour
continuer à parler peut-être qu'elle
jouera pour beaucoup d'amour à demain
quelqu'un
[Musique]
et
d